[موسيقى] مرحبًا سيمون،
من الرائع أن أكون هنا، من هم
البطل دبي ديزرت كلاسيك ونحن في
رحلتنا لنصبح حدثًا معتمدًا جغرافيًا
ونحقق صافي الصفر وتحقيق
ذلك في الصحراء هو هدف طموح، فالاعتماد
الجغرافي هو لعبة الجولف
المعتمدة عالميًا البيئية.  التسمية والمعيار
الذهبي للأندية لتحقيق
الاستدامة،
لذلك نحن في السنة الثانية من هذه
العملية ونأمل أن نصل إلى
هناك هذا العام ولكننا سنواصل
السعي للوصول إلى المكان الصحيح ولكن
أحد المخاوف الكبيرة التي كانت لدينا  كانت
المولدات يمكنني سماع
طنين المولدات، فأنت بحاجة إلى مولدات
للأحداث المؤقتة وأحد
الأشياء الكبيرة هو الوقود الذي
نستهلكه، وقد اتخذنا قرارًا منذ عام
للذهاب لاستخدام أحداث الوقود الحيوي
مثل هذه التي تستهلك كميات كبيرة من الطاقة و
في حين أن التحول إلى البيئة باهظ
الثمن، يقول سايمون إنه يؤتي ثماره على
المدى الطويل، فقد
اعتقدنا أن ذلك سيكون أكثر
تكلفة بكثير، لكنه في الواقع لم
ينجح في أن يكون أرخص لأننا
نحرق وقودًا أقل، لذلك كانت خطوة إيجابية في
الركض من أجل  على مدار ثلاثة عقود،
يبحث منظمو دبي ديزرت كلاسيك أيضًا
عن طرق أخرى لتحقيق المزيد من الاستدامة
باستخدام الألواح الشمسية. بعض مولداتنا
في ملعب الجولف تعمل بالطاقة الشمسية، لذا
لدينا منصة عرض كبيرة في المنطقة
الخضراء الخامسة عشرة وهذه المنطقة
مزوّدة بالطاقة بالكامل.  بواسطة الألواح الشمسية
إلى محطات المياه القابلة لإعادة التعبئة بشكل
غير عادي، لذا أحتاج الآن إلى إعادة ملء
معركتي، لدينا خمسة
منها حول ملعب الجولف، وسنقوم
بتقليل 40000 زجاجة بلاستيكية تستخدم مرة واحدة،
لذا فقد أحدث فرقًا كبيرًا في
التحول إلى اللون الأخضر  إن وضع اللون الأخضر هو
المحرك الرئيسي
28 أم هذا العام، وسيكون هذا هو
التركيز الرئيسي على المناخ في دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة،
وستكون دبي والإمارات العربية المتحدة موضع التركيز، لذا باعتبارنا
حدثًا رائدًا هنا، نريد أن نكون قادرين
على القول جيدًا في الواقع أننا  بدأنا
هذه الرحلة
للتخفيف من آثار تغير المناخ جولة واحدة في كل
مرة
لقناة سي إن إن دبي
الخارجية